this wasn't what a caravan of thousands
of Hondurans expected when they entered
Mexico they gassed us and we're parents
we're here with our children this kind
of crackdown of migrants is what
president Trump's come to rely on his
southern neighbor to do he may not have
his war yet but Mexico's become the next
best thing the web of checkpoints cover
the south and president lopez obrador
even deployed the new National Guard to
stop those from Honduras Guatemala and
El Salvador getting to the US but if
let's go has become Trump's wool the
question is why well this all comes from
June 2019 when Donald Trump basically
said that unless we Mexicans contain the
flow of people from the border he was
going to impose specific tax a fee of up
to 10% to every single expert in Mexico
so for Mexico that tariff threat was
serious
eighty percent of its exports go to the
US so it clamped down and effectively
last month apprehensions on the US
border were down two-thirds from the
month before president Trump's ultimatum
but some argue that it's a short-term
solution and the root causes need to be
addressed a part of the problem it's
also happening inside Central America
both countries when the US and and
Salvador are one of the most unequal
countries in the region this is about
time for us to come to terms and try to
understand why domestic elites in these
countries are not doing enough to
redistribute resources to their people
rooting out corruption providing
opportunities so that Central Americans
don't leave hasn't been president
Trump's focus it has been part of
President Lopez of the doors he's pushed
for investment in his southern neighbors
he's also said that Mexico could absorb
those forced to flee tenemos Mazda
quarter a million blue we have more than
4,000 jobs in the southern border area
available there's shelters medical care
and work in our country
but those promises turned out to be
largely empty the majority of those in
this Caravan were quickly deported now
the message at least seems clear if
you're fleeing your homeland don't
expect help or free passage through
Mexico John Holman al Jazeera Mexico
City